Welcome to the graduate course on computer networking.
The primary goal of this course is to
provide a survey of the necessary tools, techniques,
and concepts to perform research in computer communications. This
is a project based course, and there will
be significant emphasis on hands-on experience. In networking, perhaps
more than many other subjects, realization is key.
You can read about concepts or techniques in a
textbook, but really the most effective way to learn
networking is by doing. So, you'll gain a lot
of hands on experience in this course. Through the
assignments. In comparison to an introductory networking course, which
you may have taken, this course will provide more
in depth coverage of networking topics. And, it will
also offer a crash course in some of the
available tools that are now available for performing research in
computer networking. You will gain experience, with many of
these tools, through the project based assignments in the course.